Hopefully, once your app is
launched on the Google Play store,
you will have lots of users who
will use your app constantly.
So if you've got Analytics enabled,
then every time a user does
anything with your app,
a hit will be sent to Analytics.
But now you might start worrying about
impact on performance and battery drain
from sending all these outbound requests
over the network so frequently.
Because every outbound request
needs to wake up the battery.
Relax, you don't need to
worry about battery drain,
because the engineers at Google
already worried about it for you.
They designed the Google analytics
class to batch up requests,
to reduce pings to the battery,
which means adding analytics to your app
has a minimal effect on performance and
battery usage.
Android devices have a central analytics
service, that's shared by all apps.
So when a user uses an app,
that app sends a hit request
to the analytic service.
This is not an outbound
request over the network, so
the radio receiver and
the battery are not involved.
So the analytics services collects
the hits from all the apps and
batches them up, and sends them
together in two minute intervals
With the maximum hit of 20 per batch.
It's only this batched request
that goes out over the network.
The analytics service takes
care of sending the hit
at intervals that don't have
too much impact on the battery.